as part of our coverage of Black History
Month we're exploring how students are
learning about America's past don't you
remember yesterday we showed you
examples of problematic language and
widely used textbooks and how what
students are expected to learn actually
varies from state to state our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan recently
visited a school in Maryland to see how
the district revamped its curriculum
after reflecting on how they approach
topics like slavery and civil rights
jurika loved your piece yesterday what
did you discover this time really got a
chance to speak to some of the teachers
visited a classroom students at
Montgomery County Public Schools one of
the largest districts in the nation
mostly use primary sources like letters
and speeches to learn about US history
instead of relying simply on textbooks
alone it's just one way they are taught
to think critically about our nation's
past we talked about this phrase make a
way out of no way for middle school
teacher Salvatore Essenza let's start
today history is more than just
memorizing dates and famous faces we as
America we did this and we are guilty of
it we listened in on a critical
conversation in his classroom about
America's history including slavery for
people who look at this part of our
history and go but it's over you know
everyone's equal now do you guys feel
that way but there's still like
remaining bits of it it was better than
before yes but it's still bad a sense is
the social studies department chair at
roberto w clemente middle school in
maryland it's part of the most diverse
district in the state Montgomery County
Public Schools in some ways you're
teaching them to question all the time
all the time there is no national
standard for teaching social studies so
it's often left up to individual states
and districts to decide how to teach it
do you think a lot of parents understand
that there's such a vast difference from
district to district I suspect most
parents don't
CBS news contributor dr. Abram X Ken D
is the author of the book how to be an
anti-racist and a professor at American
University one of the most precious
things
that we have in this society or the
minds of our children parents and non
parents should be ensuring that that
children their minds are being shaped in
the most accurate way possible so to
ferret Ani feel she's doing just that
she's the social studies curriculum
specialist in Montgomery County she
recently revamped the eighth grade
curriculum that teachers like Essenza
are now using it was really important to
us to make sure that we are telling an
inclusive narrative of American history
and so to get away from sort of the
dominant narrative that's focused on
presidents on generals you know the
political history some examples the new
curriculum now includes a unit on stolen
labor students also look at how and why
the Constitution protected slavery and
have lessons where they rewrite portions
of their textbooks Michael Williams
teaches high school African American
history in the district I haven't seen a
textbook that is used in high schools
that does not omit some very key not
just information but themes and so part
of our job as historians and as teachers
is to try and tell a more complete story
what's a hindrance to having sweeping
generalizations a sense as eighth
graders we spoke to say the new
curriculum has opened their eyes raise
your hand if you think this class has
taught you how to think more critically
about the information you consume I
think it has changed how we study
history because we look at history
through a white Purdue email American
lens I feel like learning through this
lens basically tells the whole story of
America about how slavery is the root
and the foundation of America and its
history we're learning how to be really
really analytical thinkers really trying
to discover for ourselves like the truth
but not everyone has been on board with
the curriculum changes there were
teachers that it was hard to for them
write I think a lot of times history
teachers they love the national story
right and the story that they were told
and taught and studied is not
necessarily the story that's part of
this curriculum why should parents why
should
ideas a-hole care about how children are
learning history we teach them
everyone's story then they're gonna
become adults that believe in everyone's
story and if we don't teach the children
correctly it's gonna be perilous for our
society honey is currently working on
revamping the district's ninth grade
curriculum which includes the civil
rights movement she says it will go
beyond well-known figures like Martin
Luther King jr. and include a focus on
the ongoing struggle groups faced in the
fight for equality this was obviously a
big undertaking shoutout to Shannon Lulu
brand and Kris out Kowski who worked the
producers on this piece but a lot of
information that we got out of these two
pieces
Bravo do this you know for doing though
caring enough to say you know there's
more to learn here yeah and those
students are so impressive and I love
you but and what was it Elizabeth all of
them that we have we spoke to Ava wants
to run for president
does she yes you know taping the archive
will on it
Rikka thank you very much